so one of the other things I didn't
mention earlier but in terms of VC
investment 101 liquidity events is how
you reel in an exit basically is how you
realize gains in an investment so that
could be a share purchase acquisition or
takeover it could also be a company
going public an IPO Direct listing
increasingly becoming part of the
conversation as well Peter I'll put this
question you given the fact that we do
have some albeit just a couple but a few
but but some startups starting to take
on more of this national security
business we're certainly seeing
companies that are staying private for
longer but if whether it's SpaceX where
there's Palantir which was started in
2004 are these companies or Palantir
specifically is this a company that will
go public and I guess is the timeframe
in terms of one of those exit strategies
the same or is elongated when you're
talking about defense uh I think it's
super elongated in Silicon Valley
generally at this point this is sort of
the an enormous shift that happened
after the 1990s where the 1990s in the
dot-com bubble everyone tried to take
companies publics put them on the stock
market as fast as possible and then you
know in the aftermath you want sort of
very profitable businesses that are at
significant scale there's a lot more
regulation around having a public a
public company and so I think I think
they're sort of uh I think in general it
has gotten elongated tremendously um
it's probably not quite as urgent for
companies to go public
there there's plenty of capital
available in the private markets to fund
these these companies over over the
years but yes there's there's you know
for both SpaceX and pound here there's
you know ultimately some kind of IPO
exit at some point in the future you can
create them liquidity programs for early
investors for employees so it's not as
though you know everybody's had to hold
the shares for 15 years since the
company was started in 2004 but but I
think um I think um you know I think I
always think one of the challenges with
taking companies public is that you can
sort of thing it's always this this
danger in a tech company for it to
become overly bureaucratized and and in
a public company you know the the
accounting people the legal people
become far more powerful and you can
sort of think of it as a as like a sort
of a coup by the accountants and the
lawyers and and so if you're still like
innovating very fast and very hard you
may want to try to defer the point at
which that that coup takes place